this is the production of Cornell
University
ok so my training is as a plant for
summative and I'm speaking on ethno
botany and i guess i will just preface
this talk saying i have some credentials
in the s no part of this since i have an
undergraduate degree in anthropology and
i crossed over and through ethnobotany
into botany they came totally confused
by all the plant names and made a career
out of it and later in my career I had
some opportunities being in Oklahoma and
collaborating with paleo ethno botanist
another Sno botanist to do some research
so there's a lot of serendipity in
research and I really liked this project
it was very different than other things
I've done and I I think it has some
merit and you can be the judge of that
so we're really focusing on three tribes
which I'll make a case for as being a
good window to look at an overall view
of s no botany of the southern plains so
we're trying to reconstruct the many
respects traditional knowledge that's
difficult task and with each generation
more and more information gets lost so
it's very challenging in many respects
ok just to start off at a general level
ethnobotany defined it's just
interactions between cultures and people
plant some people however you want to
define it and Richard schultes a lot of
you should be familiar with that name is
often called the father of modern
ethnobotany and there is an Oklahoma
connection if you're presenting with
shultis so and this is my shout out to
undergrad here she'll pee on the end if
I can't see where this thing is okay
he's on your left at the end of the
junior year going into his senior year
at Harvard she did a three months senior
thesis research with an anthropologist
in Oklahoma where he spent time with the
Kiowa and at that time nobody had
need any kind of inventory of plants
used by the highway I was a hard buffalo
hunters and the story well I'm more
complicated and then obviously that led
into an incredible career as somebody
who basically define the field of
ethnobotany you spent 12 years in the
Amazon if you weren't interested in
following up on this that classic book
by Wade Davis one river it's a good
fiction of that time spent based on his
journals a lot of its photographs or the
book gloss amazon also put together by
Wade Davis and then there's a movie just
the only cinematic portrayal or schultes
and I'm aware of embrace of the serpent
it's a colon film from columbia
nominated for Best Foreign Film Academy
Awards so a very interesting individual
and really significant okay so let's get
back into the southern plains we're not
in this other plane theory and let's
like click my heels together anyway eco
geographical setting the shaded area
from an eco region perspective this is
south central semi-arid prairie
ecosystem geographers often have a cut
off of the centering great swings in the
southern Great Plains are mostly
concerned with the southern Great Plains
and you can see basically where the
planes Apache the Kiowa and Comanche fit
in that geographic and Iker geographical
scheme it's going to be particularly
significant unlike many of the tribes
represented in Oklahoma KCA as they are
often referred to by a Comanche Apache
this was their native territory oh I
Shrunk their territory and other major
changes happen but they weren't
transported in here like the Cherokee
another southeastern tribes
whoops okay so let's look at the
cultural landscape so what we have here
is a little map and the tribes in red
were basically pneumatic hunting and
gathering tribes so they hunted bison so
they did more than hunted and gathered
plant materials and other natural
resources the agrarians humming
economies are in blue so really in the
southern plains it was really a Kiowa
the Comanche in the plains Apache and
you can see a hatched area taking in the
panhandle of Oklahoma and Texas was the
original reservation of course that's
much too large for two years later they
shrunk the res and then you had the
small area and then 1901 they basically
eliminated reservation some of our early
images are by george catlin and you can
see an image of Comanche ison hunting
there as well as a Kiowa encampment so I
maintain and I'm that's my thesis that
that KCA are an ideal group to study the
southern plains askim botany for several
reasons they've been geographic a
contiguous really for a couple hundred
years they had a similar economic base
which was basically hunting and
gathering they had a close association
from zero American contact and they
actually Confederated politically under
the medicine lodge treaty of 1867 so
from a cultural Niko Geographic and
economic strategies they were very
similar and there was much intermarriage
now these were very disparate tribes
linguistically so to put these in a
linguistic context each of those tribes
their language is in a different
language family so how do they
communicate crispy many people living in
different parts of the world learn
multiple languages unlike Americans this
is part of their growing up if they have
to interact with people they also use
sign language credits which came in very
useful in one of my field trips when I
was with a ninety six year old Apache
elder
no hearing and his son communicated by
sign language so they have a shared
cultural heritage 1700 the plains Apache
or closely allied with the Cuyler which
they've kept up all these years that's
where a lot of the intermarriage
particulars between akai when Apache in
fact for decades the Apache weren't even
knowing that they were just assumed to
be some group of Kiowa and then they
called them the Kiowa patchy and more
correctly referred to as the flames
Apache it is a dialect different from
some of the other Apache groups 1806 the
Chi wanker met at Comanche made peace
1885 they are actually forced to settle
this on your story in American Indian
history 1867 they became Confederated
and then it was like there's another
tribe in here so became a KC a
reservation in canada kc by 1886 the
american bison was functioning extra
pages and this is significant because
i'm being restricted and being basically
forced to become ranchers or farmers
which they were not their economic base
evaporated so that's one way to destroy
a cultures destroyed economy the dogs
act was enacted later which eliminated a
lot of communal man which means families
were given individual plots which left a
lot of leftover land which was in token
for settlement and the reservation
dissolved the 1901 so these are very
very significant and of course if you
talk to any of these groups I'm not
doing it justice and just going over in
such a short period of time ok so let's
look at the reservation area and there's
in red the outline of the reservation
which they were in until 1901 and this
is where most of the tribal peoples that
haven't relocated actually are today
that's where tribal headquarters are so
they were forced to settle on the
reservation home territory restricted
they were restricted to family losses so
a dramatic change particularly when they
warn farmers or ranchers there are no
bison and it's a very sad point in their
history very proud people have to fight
for scraps thrown off the back of a
wagon basically and traditional
knowledge of course lost in every
generation a familiar familiar story so
let's look at the objectives of this
this is really more of a meta-analysis
where I've taken data and then tried to
assemble it and then do different
analyses with the data in this case the
raw data our plant list use of plants so
I wanted to reconstruct their floristic
and ethnobotanical resources to get that
kind of baseline look at their use
patterns in a floristic context and in
an ethnobotanical context like how many
plants would they use I mean what
percentage of for hazardous compared to
other groups etc and test the my
policies on recorded versus potential
economic plant resources underreporting
of economic plant use and loss of
traditional knowledge these are
difficult things to get at but it's
something that anthropologist social
sciences and the botanists have to deal
with and I mean in some respects were
reconstructing things in scientific
research we try to get data and we try
and make inferences that are consistent
with that data and propose hypotheses
okay the methods compiling the economic
plant data from the few surveys that are
out there from some direct communication
with some of the tribal members and
other scattered sources in the
literature sometimes almost anecdotal
and that's the trouble with any
meta-analysis you can have different
kinds of data and you kind of have to
standardize and bring it in and try and
figure it out
reconstruct floors for a South Central
Prairie ecoregion as well as for their
reservation and a lot of this relied
very heavily on the databases listed at
the bottom so we can't underestimate the
value of some of these databases and
it's invaluable I could not do this kind
of work otherwise and as most people who
use databases and there's resources the
in Native American Esteban d database in
particular was very useful for looking
at tribal and plant resources ok now I
was fortunate and this also kind of
initiated the study and that there were
three important surveys in this group in
particular the plains Apache you'll
notice judy jordan published a book in
2008 and i was instrumental in working
with her she had done her work in the
early 1960s three summers of intensive
fieldwork he was granted a master's
degree and her master's thesis was find
out by people all over the country why
this woman did not get a PhD is a sad
story but anyway and she lives less than
a mile from where I live so I looked her
up she got her notes together she
published it so I was very pleased with
that but there's schultes book so three
months going into senior year ended up
with a critical publication and really
the best summary of plan she's by the
Kiowa the Comanche a group out of
Michigan they had a Michigan or
ecological summer station there only
Jones with the botanist I believe those
vouchers are at Michigan that Schultz
these ones are at Harvard and Judy
Jordans are at Oklahoma so let's get
into some of the summary of the data
okay
so I was able to pull these data and
quantify it so if we look at the Chi web
we can verify that 88 species were
recorded the Comanche is much less 68
and so I spent more time looking through
the Michigan vouchers which were
actually not in the Michigan herbarium
but we're in anthropological collections
and luckily I was able to identify some
of the vouchers but Timothy vouchers
were fragments of wood and I did not
identify some of those and their planes
Apache you which actually took place
over three years at a much greater
numbers there's some lessons in terms of
fieldwork in terms of informants etc
security had multiple informants male
and female over multiple summers from
different family groups as opposed to
one or two male impairment during a
three-month period so let's look at the
totals I was able to look at the species
present at least one tribe about 175 and
species recorded for use among all tried
so we have three ethnobotanical surveys
only 17 oh those are reported in all
three drives so a lot of these data on
me up here in one survey most of these
are native to the southern plains
ninety-four percent 164 fibernet native
the North America that have found
outside the region and amazing through
trading they were significant plants
from the south or west mostly and there
were also some exotic species not native
6pcs so I like this graphic and other
individuals have as well because i think
it visually portrays the effect of an
obviously related group that shared a
lot of the same knowledge of the
resources and how little overlap there
was from independent researchers during
the survey
the number of species for the Kiowa
Apache Comanche here's a 17 that were
shared and then you can see some are
shared between the Apache nakaya's
summer and surveys Comanche and Kiowa
and then 35 between the Apache so by
portraying it this way you realize that
a lot of the information really just
surfaced in one lesson botanical survey
which means a lot of information which
was probably there was not was forgotten
like some of the informants firms not
recorded or whatever sometimes its
proprietary and in the case of healing
plants etc let's look by category so
there's lots of things you can do once
you get these kinds of data so these are
species used in at least one tribe out
of 175 a large portion of that are
edibles that makes sense this is the
major supplement to the protein source
being primarily I sandy not exclusively
richer or medicinal plants also a major
major category this is not surprising
this is through most natural botanical
research a large number again used for
material culture this is quite important
as well personal care and adornment it
drops off quite a bit as you might
suspect but most of the many plans and
multiple users they could be edible
component or a different plant part
could be easily differently so that they
could be used materially so edible
plants and in this category I'm keeping
it with broad strokes and we have
foodstuffs beverages masticatory
additives 91 species a lot of these have
underground parts another major
proportion or than half these
reproductive parts fruits feed and 20
species sac stems leaves etcetera and
two common ones which you're familiar
with well here
with these Ruth graver which is
widespread and new far this year as well
which is widespread material culture is
very important and if you don't think it
is see how well you survive out there
without not just your iPhone everything
else that we purchased construction
materials die fibers resins
miscellaneous products a major major
category fibers yogic lanka which is
also multiple uses whether that was
edible as well the young stems which are
kind of like asparagus as well as the
possums are edible and then the fibers
and a roughly dogwood which is common in
that region which often produces a lot
of stems from a crown that a equal
diameter so they make great airship and
ritual medicinal plants many of these
are quite well known used such as
echinacea why do you want to use not
just in this region peyote a peyote has
been in use for thousands of years and
remember the Comanche were part of the
KCA and they were really wide resume
Nick I were to go to Comanche roamed all
over from Mexico left in an earlier
plane and a lot of what they did is take
boat wood and other things and they were
prayed but they got exposed to biotech
introduced it in Oklahoma so the
oklahoma-based tribes the KCA as well as
the cheyenne and arapaho very critical
it is introducing peyote and development
of the Native American church white sage
brush which is also well known here is
widely used personal door
personal care not so many cc's an
artificial ossa this is the mixed
numbers I'm Amy AC commonly used as a
perfume and those hot southern plains
summers of perfume could be a good thing
if you walk through this it's very very
aromatic with lots of multiple
terpenoids s gal bean this is actually a
psychoactive plant but a particularly
dangerous plan its leg you mean you can
see a low meant there like a peanut but
these are very toxic and it's very
difficult to modulate the amount taken
without it being kind of drop it kind of
like jimsonweed very similar and psycho
it's grandma Buddha Lewis very
interesting in the sense that the Condor
all the inflorescences on one side of
the stem look very similar the war
Lancer was very common as it were
particularly in ceremonies many these
had multiple uses to the most common
ones would be cacti prettier which are
abundant in this region edible material
culture ritual medicinal as well as
black walnut any black walnuts here
there's another species of walnut two
small fruit woman microcarpa edible
material culture ritual medicinal
multiple uses for these plants I just
want to go through a couple plants and
then we'll look at the data from a
couple different perspectives so some of
the representative plants the junipers
and junipers virginiana people are
familiar with this is the structural
material for a lot of TP and things of
that nature get away from the Rockies
you don't have lots of all time that's
the name logical that you can use the
feeders that there's a western theater
on limestone that pops up and I'm
particularly pleased with this one
because I found this out by really
talking to a couple the elders in the
Apache they took me to a spot where they
have
a different feeder with a different
smokes obviously a different terpenoid
composition and a different colored
fruit there you know your cones and I
what there and as soon as I saw it I
knew it was control your eyes so we were
able to actually add that to the list
and that was on a sacred mount so I felt
very privileged I went there with the
ninety six year old next chair of the
Tribal Council who couldn't climb the
hill but he wanted to see it one last
time cuz I lived three months after that
and he was the last native speaker for
that dialect but museum at the
University of Oklahoma has a very active
program of recording languages and
stories by native speakers and so
there's quite an audio library for that
planes Apache dialect because the son
who I two new songs and knew some plants
that have no idea what the songs meant
or what the plants were used for so
that's a good example just one
generation loss of traditional knowledge
Bois d'Arc or two from Texas mo dark
Osage orange this is a member of the
more racing a mulberry family this is
the preferred what would for those
particularly a mixture of the heartwood
with the SAP with that interface and you
split the wick radially and this was the
preferred little bit throughout the
trains region while that's little in
black microcarpa as well as [ __ ] jus
glad and very widely used and they
appreciated its beauty as well is
arguably one of the most beautiful
screen of North American woods and
here's a Kiowa cradle board that's quite
spectacular as well as being functional
white sage brush very very well-known
including in this region Artemisia
ludowici on it there's a plant database
map
I guess you don't have it if you're up
in Alaska but no they're not widely
widely used I guess Alabama people are
missing out on this I won't comment on
that road okay Indian bread rudeness the
last of these on show very very critical
plant it's still fairly abundant in the
northern brings a lot of the soon have
these plants and include them in their
ceremonies but it's getting much more
difficult to find in the southern plains
very important edible but there are six
plants not native to North America
wormwood and aligned watercress sweet
clover Johnson grass and yet they were
used quite a bit so when plants became
energy and the native peoples found them
they knew of the use that knowledge
spread and he incorporated into their
repertoire so and a lot of these have
been around a long period of time so
they were significant many of these
plants used by the KCA were also used
outside in the southern plains usually
it depends on the natural distribution
of the plants most of the KCA plants are
going to be plants found in the North
American prairie and the southwestern
our Sonoran floristic provinces but so
yoga Glaukos you can see which is mostly
midcontinent as a mid continent tribal
youth pattern western soapberry much
more southwestern pick up the pop go as
well as the KCA and ruth flavor is used
by a multitude of tribes reflecting its
distribution now if we look in the
archaeological record and a lot of these
records are come from the flotation
method lot of these are two are
coalified you have 70
I played from Great Plains in the
archaeological record and for those who
may not be familiar it's generally
divided into the paleo-indian basically
10,000 years and older the Archaic
period about 1000 BCE woodland and then
the plains village urging into the
modern so that's your scale and if we
look at some of the case see a species
that are in the archaeological record
most of this data you say they are by
Gina Tony's very difficult to define to
identify a lot of species and our chart
qualify on the 47 appear in the
archaeological record if we go back in
time plaint village woodland RK Theriot
you can see you drop off the number of
plants but there's five plants story use
that has been in use for much greater
than 2,000 years that's pretty
impressive the other thing that's
interesting is there's several species
in the records don't show up in a kc a
record so we look at goosefoot kina
podium that is it kc a plant carbonized
and some pwede in the sunflower family
I've annual very widespread throughout
its range historically in the philly
electro botanical record no record for
the KCA that's true for many cultural
seems that once corn came in they
dropped a lot of these grains that were
more like famine food so these are
defied plants that have a greater than
10,000 year record which I find pretty
impressive goosefoot chokecherry to
Ralphie which you may not be familiar
with under the Mallo family sunflower as
well as the [ __ ]
so if we summarize the botany need in an
ethnographic context we'll see that
there's a wide variety of plants use
okay there are a lot more than just
bison monolithic bison hunters and a lot
of the plants used or used by other
tribes there is a lot of communication
shared knowledge which makes has good
survival value it makes perfect
sociological sense there's a long
history of usage for many of these
plants thousands of years in the region
even with the Edmund flow of different
cultural groups so I'm proposing that to
combine data particularly given the
nature of the botanical surveys result
is a much more complete view of the
plants used by the individual tribes and
probably is a more accurate reflection
of their collective knowledge base of
plant resources of course once you get
this there's a lot of other questions
how many planets that they use how
thorough are some of these surveys kind
of partially answered that question the
real tricky when can we estimate loss of
traditional knowledge other than saying
traditional knowledge is lost in each
generation which it obviously is but
it's difficult to kind of quantify some
of these or get a more robust hypothesis
so I reconstructed the floor of the KCA
read this is where the database has come
in and came up with 1289 species for
this seven County region in southwestern
oklahoma as well as the concern with the
natives so that's a fair number I also
went in which was a lot more challenging
and tried to reconstruct the native
floor of the southern south central
great plains ecoregion thanks for the
great plains was of limited use because
of the region that it covers corporate's
the northern plains as well
so I came up with 28 39 native species
air 1289 native species for the reds and
then looking at those reservation plants
with economic uses elsewhere north
america 508 are recorded so almost two
out of five plants on that reservation
at some documented history of use by
Native Americans two out of five there's
a lot of grass species in there a lot of
leg in species a lot of aspiration
species but two out of five were useful
and that's pretty remarkable now not all
of those were used but that's the
potential resource so in the south
central plains you see a much smaller
percentage about six percent and I'm
sure the mountain the numbers are much
larger with their range restriction a
lot of that extra reservation Florham
what's probably Bratton and they used
164 native plants that I can document
out of 1280 and that's 12 points
represent now that's the figure that's
actually very similar to well documented
at the botanical surveys elsewhere in
the world but it's hard to get a kind of
data because of the tribal whenever
group you're studying is just part of a
larger region when they don't just have
a floor that close this example would be
a Pacific island we have a discrete
floor a discrete culture and you can
look at a percentage of that floor and
we're getting pretty close to what other
people have recorded but still there's
only one third of the plants 164 out of
5 08 that are actually used or at least
recorded for use so again potential
economic species almost 40% actual if we
combine the data from KCA you see we get
a 12 point seven percent which actually
most ethno botanist feel comfortable
with but if we just look at individual
surveys you can see the numbers
that much reduced 6.4 4.7 7.8 because of
the close ties again going back to my
original argument I think this we're
getting closer to having an accurate
reconstruction of the ethno botanical
base so getting to the summaries key
points of the youth patterns at twelve
point seven percent almost thirteen
percent it's actually very similar to
the floor of South Africa totals where
they looked at how many plants were used
based on the floor as a whole but of
course there's many many different
regions in South Africa and that's the
RSA people have people heisman sound
like Donald Trump up here talking to as
no botanist who have done fieldwork
somewhere around ten percent is often in
wonder that they come up with in terms
of a ballpark percentage of the floor
that's actually used the noting one
third is the native plants the potential
useful plants are actually used and
forty percent of that has have been used
by some groups so getting to the
conclusion what kind of evidence do we
have for lots of traditional knowledge
and again we do the best we can with it
hello usage of economic plants within
the floor of the historic range there
are other factors complicating these but
that's certainly a contributing factor
only thirty percent of the species
recorded freeze of potential plants are
actually used so it's most undoubtedly
and underestimate what we're coming up
with obviously like in any culture
transcultural dispersal of knowledge and
resource use is very important let's
look at the shredded cord if you need an
example thirty percent of the exotic
flora this use economically and then
many KCA plans for widely used among
other drive there is obviously much
communication mellow Lotus why they use
exotic yellow sweet clover second
conclusion side evidence for
underreporting of s no botanical data
and I think this may be some of the more
significant results of interest
ethnobotany we get very low numbers on
these individual servings compared to
competitors when we pull it we actually
get a much more reasonable number so I
think there's a definite underreporting
and some of these surveys limited
overlap among tribes just get the meson
graphic sampling questions you just
can't go in and talk to one person
imagine if you were interviewed tell me
everything about Newark ok I'm going to
get a very highest and minimalist subset
so and lastly many regional economic
species listed are not recorded again in
the surveys sorry I kind of almost end
here with this picture of selfies again
and this is a shout-out than you
undergrad you never know where your
undergraduate projects are going to
teach hey Michelle teams signed up for
summer and that sounds good i can write
my senior thesis on that this entire
career and it really changed the
landscape of science in several
disciplines so there he was probably 21
years old that's the morning after a
coyote rich would you notice he still
has his tie on she's been described as
patrician and dig where tiny amazon ok
for acknowledgement certainly i want to
acknowledge GCA tribe it's their
knowledge and interactions
with them and some of the
representatives they've been very happy
in caesars data resurrected Judy Jordan
who wrote that sakky we've been given an
honorific title within two planes Apache
Tribe and she brought plans for their
attention that they forgot about way
back there in the cultural knowledge
somewhere Chloe Bochy used to be in
Hawaii and Britt now he's independent in
the Pacific Northwest helped quite a bit
with some of my Aristocats know
botanical analyses from colleagues at
Oklahoma Paul minutes Bailey was no
botanist no he likes his plan charcoal
aside I assume that's not true for their
horse department and a couple grad
students and Mormon who put together
that incredible databases is very
helpful he's retired now but he still
keeps the database active other people
help kind of flattering oversees the
answer of collections at Michigan all
these people are very helpful in putting
this together so that's all I have thank
you and I'd be happy to answer some
questions question I have one weight
yeah what evidence is there of any of
these tribes cultivating any of these
plants as opposed to simply gathering
them from the wild well many times there
is the model out so the question was
about where any of these wild plants
actually cultivated I mean they were
mobile people but at the same time and
so they really took careful stock of
their resources I'm because sometimes
they always follow the route they kind
of knew were some of the plants were and
it's very possible they did that
certainly if we look at some examples
it's very common in some cultures for
people particularly like to learn
there's or whatever to transplant plants
into a medicinal gardens
and some of that may have happened
particularly if there was a route in
their psychic ability so they can come
back and do or certain plants vs. that's
likely but we have no direct evidence of
that it's been a real issue with
something like some weed which is really
widespread in the archaeological record
but it's not reported among many extant
tribes at all it's like they just
dropped it and then it appears in such
numbers on our logical record to make it
seem like they were actually it was like
an incipient cultivar in fact
individuals are actually trying to
redevelop some weed I have not eaten
offense but then so I don't have any
direct evidence of that yeah addition to
a simple chemical surveys did any of the
researchers including yourself look at
cultural works such as creation stories
for fur mentions of significant plans
for these other actual instructions for
how you speak plan right so the question
is about whether we researchers have
also looked in the like creation stories
or that would incorporate some of these
significant plans and i have not
directly are several good ethnographic
books and investigations of the KCA and
i have not come across that and some of
those i tried to peruse a lot of that
literature and a lot of these living up
there reference in the native language
that language has at least English
equivalents or you could check it out
and I'd have to add some of my
anthropological colleagues and I mean
here's a member of the Kiowa tribe only
owe you an anthropology exactly for
example he teach Kiowa I mean you can do
your language requirement learning Tyler
yeah so yeah I'm not aware of any
yeah Jerry Wayne if you look across the
range from the plants for the best known
that show up most surveys on down to the
ones that you have the fewest records
for is that axis about the commonality
of the plants for certain types of uses
more likely to be showing up in more
lists well okay so the question was
plants that are commonly recurring
whether it reflects more that they're
very common or they have a significant
really significant excuse the answer
seems to be more towards the significant
component it's something I mean there's
a lot of plants that may be part of the
knowledge base but they may be less
desirable it's kind of like food there's
always going to be preferred food less
preferred food and then famine food
nevertheless the plants that really I
mean there's like a Dirty Dozen many
times that just keep appearing and all
these surveys and because they are so
critically important and corpus is one I
mean in the peyote sounds gorgeous
leaves you know this move yeah yeah
happy times mentioned that he Stacy's
there Casey a tribes were in three
different linguistic groups but there
was probably a lot of exchange of
knowledge on usage of particular species
goes on i guess like the nomenclature it
attacks on the actual or the names that
they refer to those perhaps got
transferred from culture to culture and
if you could kind of come up with the
timeline know that this is the Comanche
tribe use this plant first and that name
got passed along to be a pad is there
any cases like that we making furniture
and so the question is about some of the
naming used by the different tribes
particularly given the fact that there
at least be languages and three
different families
I guess I'm I have not looked into that
I guess the way I approach this topic as
you might guess is as a botanist doing
ethnobotany as opposed to an
ethnographer doing it no Bonnie so I
have not looked into that I mean we have
the names and there are experts and even
driveable members that are familiar with
the language that one could test that
and that would be very interesting to
look at it but unfortunately I I have
not pursued that nasty I think we have
time for one more question does Geneva
have questions bill get ya how many
families are they were my these plants
that they commonly should not only
commonly but entirely huge yeah I didn't
include that kind of information not on
this this talk so I have to go into my
data archive in my brain there's quite a
large number in my primary database
involve a nice taxonomically by family
there's at least 65 families and that
may be in an underestimate these things
like rose AC are very common and things
like fab AC are very common but there
are no seeds like in seeds that were
used which and there weren't any grass
seeds that i recorded i expected drop
feed / obolus or something like that to
pop up they've appeared another survey
so I think those are areas where you
know pathologist ahmad Jenner would be
with their be more sharing us Jenner
among the free shots and of species yes
and and a lot of my members are going
down to the species level and sometimes
they didn't you know it depends on the
plant because different species are
often referred to as a cousin so this is
a cousin
of another prunus and they leave it at
that so there is some information that
that's you know there's a little bit of
error in that data in the sense that
they often did not discriminate so the
genus and that's an interesting point
that you do to her directly illusion the
genus is actually very very critical
element in a lot of non-western taxonomy
but depending on on the plant this
species can be important as well so I
want to thank for cancer Ellison's for a
fascinating presentation thanks this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu